[Music]
Frankie Muniz is on a quest for that
Dancing with the Stars Mirrorball and on
Monday night he and Whitney will dance
through another ballroom champ her
former partner and sitcom star falls
over a barrel I know enough on so for a
long time the first rehearsal I felt
like I was trying to keep up I was
really impressed with how quickly you
were picking it up there's three weeks
knock I don't want to look back and go
man I should have pushed harder living
with no regrets is a motto of Frankie's
before today's rehearsal he stopped by
et to do a Facebook live and talk about
his journey back into the spotlight when
I left the business I started doing
other things and made me appreciate
everything that I had been through and
had done so much more Frankie was 14
when he landed the starring role on
Malcolm in the Middle
it's so awesome he credits his love of
the show for keeping him on the straight
and narrow I was always just so grateful
and happy to be doing what I was doing
to this day I've never drank a sat
alcohol I've never even come near a drug
the show ended in 2006 and Frankie left
Hollywood to be a racecar driver after a
nasty crash in 2009 that broke his back
he left the sport to pursue music
in 2012 another health challenge he was
diagnosed with a neurological condition
and since then has suffered several mini
strokes he's also dealing with long term
memory loss
his girlfriend Paige is a support system
she writes he's you know amazing
detailed descriptions of our days and I
can read them and they really do bring
me back to the moment which is pretty
cool we've been together about two years
now 31 Frankie is considering a return
to acting if I come back as an actor
which I'd love to like I have a greater
appreciation for everything and I think
my work ethic is like a lot stronger
than then maybe it was when I was a kid
[Music]
his stint on Dancing with the Stars is
certainly raising his profile he's a
front-runner after two perfect scores
this week
[Applause]
[Music]
and a fan favorite even TV dad Bryan
Cranston is cheering him on he's in
London the email music here's so amazing
I'm so proud of you like kill it
he ended it with like keep it up son I
mean it really is a good 500 people
[Music]
you